Speaker 1: We've been extensively covering
the growing civil war within the Republican
Party.
The battle lines are not super clear, but
to some degree, at least at the very top level.
The battle lines are pro-Trump and anti-Trump
Republicans, and one really interesting figure
in that is Florida Governor Ron DeSantis.
And he's interesting because it's not exactly
clear which side he's on.
And what I mean by that is early in the pandemic,
when the failed former President Donald Trump
was still the actively failing President Donald
Trump.
Ron DeSantis and Trump were very buddy buddy.
Early in the pandemic, DeSantis refused to
close and or very quickly opened major events,
sporting events, all sorts of different things.
Trump pointed to dissent.
This is a guy doing the right thing.
And they were very buddy buddy.
Over time, it started to become clear that
there was at least some appetite from within
the Republican Party for an alternative to
Trump.
And while the alternative that they seem to
be seeking is not, you know, Mitt Romney,
it's it is Ron DeSantis, to some degree.
Ron DeSantis has increasingly been thought
of as an alternative to Trump.
Now it's weird because DeSantis is almost
like Trump to the nth degree.
DeSantis has a lot of the same terrible ideas
of Trump, the same political instincts of
Trump, but he's more competent and he's less
cartoonish, and he's probably more dangerous
if he gets the opportunity to be president
of the United States.
But so kind of by default, there started to.
Be this well, will it be Trump 2024 or will
it be DeSantis 2024?
And this has really triggered Donald Trump
to the point where we now have multiple reports.
We've told you about where Trump is reportedly
furious that, for example, when DeSantis is
asked, Hey, will you run in 2024?
DeSantis doesn't go, Oh, absolutely not.
It's Trump's for the taking.
DeSantis hasn't said that, and there are numerous
reports that Trump and people around him are
upset about that.
This brings us to this past weekend at Mar
a Lago and at Mar a Lago.
Roger Stone, who was a guest on this program
and was was ultimately convicted and then
pardoned, and he's a friend of Trump.
OK, whatever.
Roger Stone was filmed at Mar a Lago, and
he goes up to Trump, and he says, Ron DeSantis
is a piece of s.
And that video was initially kind of cut,
so you don't really see what Trump's reaction
is.
Now the fuller video has been released.
I'm going to play it for you now.
Of course, if you're listening, you're not
going to know what Trump does.
But the big deal that's being made is Trump
nods when Roger Stone tells them Ron DeSantis
is a piece of ass.
Let's take a look at the video.
Let's take a listen to the video.
Unidentified: Yes, Roger.
How could I not see?
Speaker 1: OK, so listen, this is not like
the big smoking gun that Trump has, the player
declared open season on Ron DeSantis or anything
like it.
There's also we can't ignore that there's
really strange kind of like godfather vibes
at the start of the first Godfather movie
incredible movie.
By the way, when I sometimes when I mentioned
The Godfather, people email saying I'm glorifying
violence because it's a violent film.
No, it's just a great film.
The scene at the wedding, where everybody
is kind of making their pilgrimages and saying,
Hello, thank you, Godfather, I have a favor.
I need this.
I need that.
Oh, you're so great.
There's a similar vibe to it that's developed
at Mar a Lago, with people coming and making
their pilgrimages to Trump.
But putting that aside, there is no question
that Donald Trump is now hostile to Ron DeSantis,
and it's increasingly clear that voters are
aware that there is an alternative to Donald
Donald Trump.
So we've looked at these numbers before, and
they continue to improve slightly.
And Ron DeSantis is favor.
If you go to predict it, dawg, where you can
bet on who will be.
You can bet on almost anything.
They'll take your action.
But one of the things is you can bet on who
will be the 2024 Republican nominee.
Last time we looked at this, it was 39 29.
Thirty nine percent believed it would be Trump
and 29 percent believed it would be DeSantis
that was the closest it had been since the
start of, you know, the discussion of 2024.
It is now tightened up a little bit more where
now it is 38 30.
This is based on money betting.
These aren't polls, but if you look at how
people are betting.
Thirty eight percent now believe Trump will
be the nominee and 30 percent believe it will
be Ron DeSantis.
There is no way Trump's not aware of these
numbers, and DeSantis is quickly gaining ground
on Donald Trump.
This is the tightest that it's been.
Now, if you look at actual polling, the most
recent polling I found is from a couple of
months ago, actually almost three months ago.
And there you had Trump at 57 percent.
This was a Harvard Caps Harris poll it had
three months ago.
Trump was at 57 percent among Republicans.
And DeSantis and Pence each had 12.
Now that's three months ago.
The numbers may well have tightened since
then, but there is, let me put it, a different
way.
It is not a foregone conclusion that if there
is a contested 24 primary and Trump runs and
DeSantis runs, that Trump runs away with it
there sent the Sanders has growing support.
And increasingly, people believe he has a
real shot.
And that's the first step in having a shot.
People believing you have a shot, it becomes
a sort of self-fulfilling prophecy.
So expect that it will get delightfully ugly.
If both Trump and DeSantis keep pointing towards,
I may indeed run.
Let me know your thoughts.
We'll have the clip of Roger Stone and Trump
at Mar a Lago on our Instagram, which you
can find at David Pakman show.
Let's talk a little bit about radical Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene really
the worst of the worst of American politics.
If you imagine for a second, oh, let's say
we were sending some elected officials to,
you know, pick a country wherever Ireland
to represent the best of the United States
House and Senate.
Marjorie Taylor Greene is basically the most
humiliating person you could send along with
a couple others Madison Cawthorn, Louie Gohmert,
Lauren Boebert, Matt Matt Gaetz.
These types of people.
OK.
So she's facing some problems.
The first problem is that a judge has ruled
that the effort to remove Marjorie Taylor
Greene from her reelection ballot in November
upcoming now in a few months can go forward
now.
The judge hasn't said she's off the ballot.
The judge has said the effort can, in principle,
go forward.
This is absolutely fascinating and this is
going to be a legal fight.
So let me explain what's going on or we're
going to look at the New York Times report
from This Morning.
A federal judge cleared the way for a group
of Georgia voters to move forward with legal
efforts seeking to disqualify Greene from
running for reelection.
Why?
Well, citing her role in the Trump riots,
the disqualification effort is based on a
constitutional provision adopted after the
Civil War that barred members of the Confederacy
from holding office.
It mirrors several other cases involving Republican
members of Congress, whose roles leading up
to and during the Trump riots have drawn criticism.
The judge was appointed to the District Court
for the Northern District of Georgia by President
Barack Obama and denied Marjorie Taylor Green's
request for a preliminary injunction and temporary
restraining order.
In the 73 page ruling, Judge Totenberg wrote
that Greene had failed to meet the burden
of persuasion in her request for injunctive
relief.
This case involves a whirlpool of colliding
constitutional interests of public import.
The novelty of the factual and historical
posture especially assessed in the context
of a preliminary injunction.
Motion has made resolution of the complex
legal issues, particularly demanding.
The argument that Greene made is there is
no way to resolve this fully before the primary
on May 24th, and absentee ballots are going
to start being mailed in on April 25th, so
there's no way to fully adjudicate this in
time.
And the argument from the judge here is, Greene
is arguing, sort of like procedure like the
primaries really soon, and there's no way
to decide this now.
The judge determined Greene hasn't shown that
it's likely she would succeed on the merits,
so she went.
But Marjorie Taylor Greene went on Tucker
Carlson's show last night, and she's flipping
out.
Listen to what she had to say.
Speaker 4: I have to protect myself.
I have to go to court on Friday and actually
be questioned about something I've never been
charged with and something I was completely
against.
And so this is how far it's going.
These leftists, these progressives who would
rather want, they'd rather have the judge
or bureaucrats making decisions instead of
voters.
They want to hand that over to them and not
let the people in my district even have the
right to vote for me.
But now the Republican Party, now
Speaker 1: that's a very dishonest argument,
because this is sort of like saying, Hey,
you know, there's rules about who can be in
the House and Senate.
And for example, if a member of the House
were convicted of a crime and then forced
to resign, anybody could get up there and
say, you know what?
The right of the people to just decide, given
that this individual was convicted of a crime,
do we still want them representing us or not?
That's being denied to them.
Right.
But these are the rules.
These are the rules and the law is.
You can move to have someone taken off of
a ballot if you can prove that they did certain
things.
That's so it's very naive or cynical or just
dishonest to say, oh, the people aren't being
allowed to just voice their opinion, well,
there are times where we say you can't be
on the ballot
Speaker 4: to fight harder, Tucker.
You know, there's something that we that I
have learned, and I think this is really important.
You know, if you can challenge any representative's
candidacy or elective elected officeholder,
then I bet you we could round up.
Some Republican voters who didn't like Kamala
Harris,
Speaker 1: by the way, still can't pronounce
Carmella's name
Speaker 4: funding rioters, criminal rioters
out of jail or Ilhan Omar or Cori Bush or
Maxine Waters.
Speaker 1: And now what do those four women
have in common?
Hold on a second.
Kamala Harris, Ilhan Omar, Cori Bush, Maxine
Waters.
There's something similar about them, right?
I'm trying to know why.
Why is she mentioning those four fighting
riots?
Speaker 4: You know, I think there's there's
another way to play this.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, this is also absurd
what she says, because this is exactly what
they did to Joe Biden when she said, You can't
just have people challenge whatever anybody,
anybody's position.
But Joe Biden won, and that's exactly what
all of you guys did.
You were like, No, he didn't win.
He doesn't get to be there.
There was no evidence for it.
There was no legal basis.
There was no factual basis.
There was no empirical basis.
So this is actually a very interesting legal
case.
If this were to work against Marjorie Taylor
Greene to keep her off the ballot.
UN theory could use it against other Pro Insurrection
Pro riot politicians.
And I'm sure that if this goes against Marjorie
Taylor Greene, she will try to appeal.
And maybe it would get all the way up to the
Supreme Court because they're actually I don't
want to pretend that the legal issue is cut
and dry.
I read a bunch of opinions this morning and
this comes down to the 14th Amendment, so
there is a constitutional issue as to whether
you really could keep her off the ballot in
this way.
There's a mechanism to request it, and if
it were successful, there would be a question
as to whether it's constitutional.
But that doesn't matter.
It's a process that is going through in her
disdain for having to participate in a legal
process.
Aside from what your opinion is of, what the
outcome should be is the exact type of entitlement
that we've seen from these people for so very
long.
But this isn't the only problem that Marjorie
Taylor Greene is having.
Let's go to the next one.